all right uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules as
usual first of all please mute yourself
during the talk if you have immediate
questions you are welcome to unmute and
ask otherwise please use the chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in the Q a session at the
end
second today's seminar is open to
external audience so no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
will be record and upload to our YouTube
channel so now let me introduce our
speaker it is an honor to host a very
coutinho who is a professor in civil
engineering and the coordinator
of the interdisciplinary area of
computational engineering and science at
copy the Alberto Lewis coimbra Institute
for Graduate Studies and research in
Engineering in the federal University of
Rio De Janeiro in Brazil he got his
daughter's degree in the same school in
1987. he is a recipient of an IBM
faculty partnership award in 2001. the
Jay Tinsley Oden faculty fellowship at
UT Austin in 2004 the Julio
messerini academic award a copy in 2007
and the International Association of
computational mechanics fellow award in
2012. Professor coutinho has organized
National and international conferences
training workshops and short courses
surfing in scientific Committees of many
conferences including the super
Computing conference design conference
on Parallel processing fella elements in
flow problems the U.S National Congress
on computational mechanics and the road
Congress on computation mechanics
he serves on Executive
Committee of the International
Association of the computational
mechanics and in the Brazilian
Association for computational methods in
engineering
he is a member of the editorial board of
international Journal of numerical
methods in engineering and computational
methods in applied mechanics and
engineering
and on the advisory report of the
international Journal of numerical
methods influence he coordinated over 80
industrial projects directed 33 PhD
physics and 37 master of science
dissertations
he is a offer of 136 peer-reviewed
Journal papers and over 450 conference
papers he was the pi of the Brazil Euro
project hpc4e high performance Computing
for energy from
2017-2000 to 2020 he is currently the pi
of the informatics network of in
artificial intelligence for renewable
energy and climate change supported by
the Rio degeneral States Agency for
research
today he will talk about enhancing data
driven workflows for complex simulations
please enjoy the wonderful talk now
without further Ado let me hand it over
to everyone
okay thanks Tony for the long
introduction you could be the shorten
one because I say I still play
volleyball okay
well it's a pleasure to be here with you
today and uh well you've seen my screen
and then what and I'm glad to you know
share with you our our review on how to
enhance data driven workflow for complex
simulations
the agenda for today is uh well uh we'll
do a quick reveal on the simulation
workflow
um then we're gonna talk about you'll
see uh how instead of visualization fits
within and how we do computational
steering
and then the first first question we're
going to address in this talk is how
snapshot based data-driven computations
fit within this simulation workflow with
instead of visualization
then we're going to see a lot of case
studies using basically a dynamic node
decomposition
um okay uh so uh there's a lot of
questions uh we see first uh we're gonna
We ask ourselves uh what would happen if
it compress the snapshots
what we do if the snapshots are not in
the same space for instance coming from
an Adaptive mesh refinement and course
computations
uh and then we're gonna you know discuss
how can we mix The Institute of
visualization workflow what is streaming
DMD is it good for anything I mean let's
let's discuss this
and in the end if I have time I will
address
um a particular
issue on DMD should we do it couple or
uncouple and uh of course it will be
open for a q a session in the end all
right uh
here here you see um the basically
simulation workflow uh it starts with
some pre-processing where you select
parameters like an initial time step the
time interval set tolerance pick up the
solvers and set up in in all the setup
for the Adaptive mesh refinement and
coursing simulation Etc
then stop time step in uh so while
you're don't reach your timing maximum
time interval your assembly and so
nonlinear equations your adaptive mesh
and the time step your update your
solution and then if if it's time save
data on disk when required update for
time step and move on in the end
you have a lot of data in the disk
you're post processing you do the post
process basically visualize the data and
extract relevant quantities of interests
uh well
a
assembly and solving in non-linear
equations by some you know new ton-like
method is where you will spend most of
your computer time
innovate step B guarantees uh accuracy
in in space and time
and step D is uh where you do IO to
persistent storage on the right you see
some solutions you know some simulations
coming from our group let's see uh that
built for one here on the top is a
solution of a non-local phase field
model with Phoenix and on the right you
can see a Time step right for for order
of magnitude adaptive time step right
for you know several order of magnitude
and below the simulation for a droplet
impact using lip mesh with adaptive mesh
refinement and coursing and you can see
you know
[Music]
that showing yeah the mesh adaptivity
uh well
many years ago
um
this basically workflow that's still is
still valid
um in this paper here that's super
computer in 2010 they realized that the
optimal complexity of this workflow is
order of n to the power 4 over 3 where n
is your the total number of your
unknowns it's easy to realize now let's
think that you have n over 3 a cube
let's say with n over three a nose in
each of the Cartesian directions and you
do a um implicit time step with the
number time step of order of n if you
get everything together you get this n
to the power of 4 3. it's optimal and
then there is only optimal if you solve
your linearized equations uh with our
now it is linear scale is linearly on
time which is hardly you know to achieve
more or less we what we see here is uh
the only way to improve this is
diminishing uh the the number of points
in space and time okay but there Remains
the i o in in persistent storage and the
visualization I mean getting Insight
from your computations all right so I
this this workflow becomes put in place
instead of visualization
uh visualization results of running
simulation instead of this is basically
do the visualization without the need to
copy data to a storage device of course
it reduces the amount of data and adds
to reducing traffic I O and volume and
you can think that you can access more
data for instance uh if you are writing
to the disk at this interval we've been
doing situ processing you can you can do
more intervals
uh
more than that people realize you know
that we can have we we can do in real
time in the simulation exploration and
the steering
um of course it produces latency latency
to the first result and avoid
large-scale post-processing
so the traditional workflow have the
simulation code dump everything to the
disk and do the visualization later
with this now we write an adapter for
this particle Catalyst which is um our
our choice for Institute of
visualization infrastructure is not the
only one and you can then produce
um using some scripts
um visualization in runtime uh new
applications you see in in in this
yellow box in the bottle are two new
applications are from the group coming
from the Ken Johnson in Colorado Boulder
that are so cool
um they do um you know they uh they go
beyond
enabling you to change your let's say
change your your uh your domain during
the simulations using using this in situ
tools and also merge
um couple uh in this institute which are
simulation workflow and the Machine
learning workflow they're so cool I
really appreciate that so much and I
encourage you to read this
so uh how it works basically in in more
detail uh the same the the workflow with
Institute of visualization and steering
here we build that on top of lip mesh
you set up the Adaptive mesh refinement
of course the setup start the simulation
setup
and then you start looping the time Loop
um you'll you know it's a couple mode
physics solvers you do the flute solver
you do the transfer equation here we are
this was specialized for uh sediment
transport you're gonna see the
application in a moment and do it need
an Adaptive mesh refinement we do the
writer and then we move to the Catalyst
adapter
call their Catalyst adapter and that was
tracked from the python script and
generating PNG files for users Visa
visualization in situ what we also do
with this tool called the effronalizer
the details are in this yellow box in
the in below in the slide is uh that we
also gather
other data that allow us to interact
with a lot of parameters in during the
simulation at runtime we we annotate
some data in the database and then we
query this database if needed in
changing everything in runtime more or
less we can see in this box here that we
are annotated no linear tolerances uh
time steps and uh and some data needed
for uh the controlling the Adaptive mesh
refinement in course in in libmesh all
right how it works okay this is a
simulation statement bring up on our
Channel this is a big Channel
and this is um you know visualization
generated in situ is a high determinant
flow it's similar can see Reynolds
remember here is 5000 and it's
interesting that we have some
experimental data and the black curve
corresponding to the Adaptive mesh
refinement and coursing simulation that
you can see on the right for a longer
time and see in in this detail here is
the adapted mesh for this configuration
so how computational steering works uh
right
so we are some user interacting with the
code series which when it's running and
then at certain point at that time step
the user decide that uh well uh let's
relax some tolerances here and see what
happens and then he can do it in runtime
and changing this tolerances and also
adapt more adaptive mesh refinement
tolerances and uh see if it's okay and
the simulation progresses well
um the air in the end what we see here
is a huge saving in computer time and we
can control this is runtime in essence
everything is uh annotated in the
database they are very frequent query
and you can interact with many
parameters in runtime so this is
basically a simulation workflow with uh
instead of visualization and steering uh
this email image that you have seen they
have been produced by The Institute of
visualization capabilities
right so now can with the data driven
reduced order model as I said before I
will restrain myself to talk about DMD
but um if I'm if I succeed in my
presentation you're gonna see that
several of those more computational
computer science things uh can be
applied to other ways of building
reduced rural models uh well the
observation from a nonlinear problem at
hand and this observation often comes
from snapshots of a large parallel
simulation with a workflow just like the
one we have uh discussing uh snapshots
are reading to disk
due to the gap between Computing and iOS
pin and a snapshot generation can become
a bottleneck particularly for large
simulation
DMD as any as several other reducer
other models builds the the reducer
robber mode of course from a single
value decomposition of the snapshot
Matrix so we ask ourselves and uh you
can see the in the yellow box here the
paper that will be building one of the
paper we're gonna be building uh my talk
today we ask ourselves those two things
in red here what happens if we compress
the snapshots to diminish IO
and also uh what happens when we merge
DMD with the simulation workflow with
Institute visualization and steering
those are the two uh things we will
address
well I mean the two next things I will
address in this talk
okay so uh this picture here is a try to
uh
to give you an idea how this workflow
will be merged we have the offline phase
in HPC machine this is a simulation with
a lit mesh and a finite element
simulation and then we have a two
branches this thunder Branch where you
dump everything to the disk but now with
uh maybe lossless and lost data
compression using one I will come back
to this one using one floating Point
compressor and then we have a compressed
snapshot that have to be decompressed to
be so can DMD can work and in the other
hand you do you have here The Institute
of visualization
um you know uh um a framework and are
running together we are the simulation
that you generate PNG files and this PNG
files generated at the runtimes are feed
are fed to the incremental DMD and can
then you can do the online phase in our
rock station or laptop
so of course I'm in this full art
assimilation take hours and of course
the MD reconstruction takes seconds
everybody knows that but most of the
tools we're gonna be using here comes
from the xscale Computing project from
the doe and that particular you can find
this in the Alpine zfp which is one of
the projects so uh uh we're gonna have
we basically gonna discuss uh here uh
what gonna happen if we do data
compression and how we merge uh The
Institute of visualization with an
incremental DMD with gun as we're gonna
see with blurry uh mix it up somehow the
offline and online phase of this uh of
this uh of the DMD workflow okay
just to make a point uh this is the
vanilla dmdriver the exact dmdr
algorithm uh you know in liberon you
have this it's just to make a point that
uh we're always going to be using a
randomizer that's different SVD and
incremental SVD okay but uh one of the
things that we have to take care is when
you do large scale simulation there's
not shots comes from those parallel
computations it they are distributed in
the file system as you can see here this
is a nice picture show you the meat is
partitioned for 16 processor for uh you
know some of the analysis we did in in
for cfd many years ago is a Los Angeles
class submarine mesh
we use this mesh for many for many you
know safety computations in the past but
my point here is that the Special Care
should be given to the subdomain
interface data in order to arrange this
not snapshots why is that so because a
partition for computing SVD which is
basically a um a dance Matrix is not
exactly the same the partition that what
when you'll do uh I mean your snapshots
that come in as a download to disk from
a a parallel simulation okay so we have
to take care of this
uh
right uh now let's get back to uh
spend a bit of time uh doing uh talking
about compressing slow Point numbers
uh well several state-of-the-art in
lossy and lossless scientific data
compressor have been evaluated recently
since the designer paper here called SDR
bench is uh bench they propose a
benchmark for scientific data reduction
for lossy compressors
there's in in this paper you can find
many and we selected zfp which is one
that operators on a three-dimensional
array by partitioning this array into
blocks or 4 to the power D values
each block this compressor decompress
entirely independently from all other
blocks
well
let me use zfp you could control the
blocks quality and compress its size by
modifying four parameters I will not go
into the Tails of this parameters but at
a high level zfp provides five
predefined compression modes that affect
these parameters expert fixed rate
sticks Precision fixed secures and
reversible uh the first four modes allow
a high compressor razor with
controllable loss of accuracy and while
the last one performs Lots less
compaction why zfv we use the FP well
because there is a strong mathematical
background there's a paper discussing
error analysis for zfp that you can see
here in this yellow box has been
published in the Scion drummer for
scientific Computing a few years ago and
that's why we adopted zfp so and more
than that we adopt the fixed accuracy
mode that given a tolerance that we
select set Min x per meter to this
expression floor Vlog to the tolerance
which means in practice that for
uncompressible floating points death in
a reconstructive value
the absolute difference of f and g is at
most two to the power Min X
uh also what is interesting is now zfp
is available as a for compression
decompression floating points uh on agf5
files format using this plugin here so
it's easy to use
right uh well let's see what gonna
happen I come back to this problem that
we analyzed in a few years ago uh is a
particle driven graph to flow in the
lock exchange here you have a water with
sediment here is clean water
is basically a couple incompressible
navier stops equation with sediment
transport at the grasshop 10 to the
power 6 actually number one which means
the floor is driven by turbulence
at uh well you can get the details um
for for the day for the initial
condition and boundary conditions in our
paper but I'm just making uh a point
here that at the bottom you have this
boundary condition for the sediment
concentration which means that sediments
are allowed to leave the domain uh we
assume the Buffs and ask hypothesis
valid particular particles have a heavy
in the heavy fluid have a negative
inertia and a much more more smaller
than the scales Barons in just fluid
motion we settle the setting velocity to
point two is the trilenear hexahedron
mesh mesh with spacing .025 we're using
the residual base operation mode to
scale finite element formulation for the
fluid and the Streamliner print petroval
Arc and finite element formulation for
sediment transport and we record the
Thousand snapshots
the forwarder model is a lid mesh
parallel simulation where they spend
roughly 80 percent of the time on the
solvers uh in less than 0.1 percent for
output writing a half Point percent of
total time for paraview catalysts and uh
18 for the remainder of the task and we
use measure for mapping DMD
approximation and modes to the original
nodes another coordinates this is a
snapshot of the simulation but you can
see the formation of the Kelvin you have
helmet holds billows
okay uh yeah so snapshot compression
this table here show the storage
requirement for the quantities of
interest in the compression rate for
these simulations you can see uh for the
raw data for the zfp with loss less
compression and uh ZF will the fixer
accuracy for two tolerances uh one more
tight and then more relaxing and and we
are recorded we are we were storing the
uh well the three velocity component uvw
the pressure the sediment concentration
and sediment deposition
uh you see that as far as some of those
variables we achieve a high rates of
compression uh you know the sediment
concentration and the deposition and
they are all uh compatible with the
people recorded in The Benchmark and I
mentioned before so this is um more or
less what people have seen uh in in in
those data sets what remains to be seen
now is that when we do this of course
we're gonna save a lot of uh of uh you
know a disk but how this will influence
GMD and liberal constructions
okay so we do the Reconstruction this
plot here in your left show you the pick
to sign noise ratio which is a measure
of how good are your
compressors in Blue uh this is the cfp
lossless PS and R in decibels around
more than 100 which is very good
uh zfp with accuracy fixer you know
previously tender power -6 is over 75
with consider it excellent and uh for um
you know keeping uh three keeping three
or four digits is not that good but is
acceptable
and the right you see the influence of
compression on the similar values uh
well the decided line represents
um you know uh the base of the 250
singular values that are going to be uh
uh we selected for the DMD
reconstruction we see a deviation on the
singular values for when we do uh uh you
know uh
when we are when we do a very aggressive
loss of compression and but the single
the singular values uh agree uh with its
right you see lots less and no
complexion are on top of each other and
we do a less aggressive we have a very
good match until let's say 350. so we're
gonna do uh we're gonna see what happens
when we do the reconstruction with uh
um uh you know a symbol of for the with
the bases built with 350 um nodes okay
oops all right but before that let's see
what happens with the DMD eigenvalue
analysis
for the loss compression for 10 or minus
six you see that all the apparently all
the eigenvalues are okay we have some
small discrepancies and we when we do
zoo in in this box but however for the
more aggressive
um compression we see a more discrepancy
in the eigen values and of course we
will it will affect
the DMD reconstructions
so uh in this table here you see the
forbenius nor relative error between the
approximating and original snapshot for
this problem consider a basis of 250 you
see the forbenders now are okay more or
less when we do no compression or loss
less compression or uh uh this I would
like 10 to the minus six accuracy they
are more or less of the same order but
they are twice as big when we do a more
uh more aggressive compression
this picture on the right see you can
see the absolute error between the DMD
reconstruction with a basis of 250 50
you know
um
when the bases are using 250 uh
eigenvector from the lossy compressor
data with the 10 to the power 6 minus
six compression and the original
snapshot for sedimented concentration at
this time so um you see very uh is more
absolute error but this is not enough
let's see more
measure other measures in the graph in
your left you see the relative error in
time measured as the difference between
the reconstructed solution and DMD
solution you see the norms and you see
that this zero is very you know
when you do no compression uh in in
Orange lots less compression in green
velocity with the tendon minus
six dollars and a more aggressive uh
compression we see a very good
error and velocity in in in lossless and
more or less on top of each other until
that time and there's a different
diversions afterwards and but uh
overall the errors is still you know low
10 below 10 to the minus two
on the right you see the time history of
the relative 7 Mass error for all cases
they are very good and when you do a
very aggressive velocity compression
decompression you see that there's some
oscillations but overall
um the mess is uh very well
reconstruction
uh finally well I mean are people who do
this simulations there are some
quantities of Interest Global contents
of interest that they always look one is
the front position over time and uh for
this which is basically uh how a uh you
compute um how where is the front over
time you can see there's a very good
match uh no matter of what you do using
raw data for the for the model raw data
from the simulation and all the
compressor compressing all the snapshots
you see for This Global quantity of
interest you are on top and also uh from
the sediment mass time history that's uh
you you see the same thing so I mean it
appears that a compressing snapshots by
uh using a uh you know uh
some with keeping some accuracy good
balance between uh you know how much
you're gonna compress
and decompress is um is a good idea by
the way the decompress time for the MD
is negligible
okay all right so uh let's see what
happens when we have a snapshots coming
for an Adaptive message refinement and
coursing
um well uh
when when you do adaptive measure
refinement course simulations
um
the meshes we have they have of course a
different number of nodes number in
order coordinates
and uh it can also lead to different
mesh topologies and instructors
for instance this is you see are three
levels of refinement and then you see a
you know I mean uh this matches of
course they don't live in the same space
and you can have something like this a
hanging node which is constrained by
their neighbors
or you can have situations like this
mesh one and message two that they have
that they have the same numbers of
degrees of freedom but different
topologies uh we circumvents this issue
by considering L2 projection of the
numerical simulation results for
different meshes
into a reference Target mesh
so there are some issues here okay uh
the choice of a proper method to
successfully project functions in
different finite element space is not a
trivial task and particularly because
conservation may not be satisfied if you
go to the literature there's there are
several walk-in addressing this issue
however
we have to bear in mind here that mass
projection for us in to build uh you
know a a DMD snapshot they occurs as a
post-processing phase after Computing
the Adaptive mesh refinement course
solution therefore it cannot lead to
cumulative errors so projection is not
that doesn't accumulate error
there's another issue here is how much
the snapshots will retain from the
original uh the original uh accuracy of
this uh adaptive mesh
so
what we found out that we need to to
choose a reference Target meshes Target
mesh with a characteristic length
equivalent with the system in adaptive
measures in order to avoid major
accuracy losses
so that how it works uh that Solution on
the dollar mesh be given by the
suspension satisfying this uh L2
projection here in the proper space
uh and of course L2 is defined by the
Target mass and in Temple Run here you a
subprot is the optimum turbulent
interpolant in this L2 North from this
space
so uh we Computing the L2 projection
this is orthogonal projectors is defined
in the following linear system uh
and you this isn't you cannot solve this
for uh you prod
where m is the standard Mass Matrix for
any finite element code NP is a
projection Matrix
uh well we prove a theorem in this paper
down here is that if every degree of
freedom of the original mesh is also a
degree of freedom of the resin F
reference mesh then the Matrix B is full
rank
right which is a very uh tough to
requirement of the math in practice
but uh we find out that uh having a
reference mesh representing defined
scale is enough for practical purpose
so this algorithm snapshot projection
will work like this they have an input
the finite and element solution
considering adaptive metric refinement
courses and the output data projects and
solutions
so for each observation time step you'll
apply that to projection and stack the
result in snapshot Matrix or output the
projected solution to this compressor or
not compressor doesn't matter on the
right you can see um his is the you know
I mean it's a simple exercise
we project this solution and this is
adapted mesh and this is an infinite
Norm this is one and then you use this
mesh with represented finite scale here
the projection is very good or if we
project in a totally unstructured mesh
more or less keeping the same scale we
have also a very good a uh very good uh
error
right so let's check out how it works in
practice
let's examine right now the problems of
a 3D ryzen bubble which basically a
couple Navia stocks equation I'm sorry
just one second
is a couple navigational equations with
a convected level set where we consider
surface tension with continuous surface
model the details are in the paper
in this yellow box here and this is the
initial condition and no slip boundar
condition applied to all boundaries the
computational domain is this box here
we're going to have grid size in this
interval there will be 240 time steps uh
this is the time step the bubble radio
the density position the the properties
and we consider gravity like this
so first thing is
um
how this idea of looking at projected
meshes work
we can see here in this plots the
Adaptive mesh solution the projection
for this time step on a course mesh in
intermediate mesh and a fine mesh
projection and in the table here you can
see how costly is the perception you see
uh well for fine mesh is the projection
cost is negligible and uh is uh it's a
projection like this out to projection
is available on this uh either uh is no
it's part of a lib mesh it's part of
Phoenix so projection is not an issue
the issue here is uh how the solution
becomes when you really do the
take a look on the solution quality in
this projected meshes
so uh you see some quantities of
interest for this problem this is the
volume of the bubble this vericity uh
the rise velocity and the center of mass
uh for the you know uh forward
assimilation with adaptive mesh and for
Ma and the output in the with the course
intermediate and find projection of
course the course
um the project the solution project and
the course match is good for nothing but
for the intermediate uh mesh and the
fine one there are you know this
quantities are all okay which it gives
us a good indication that uh projector
projection can give you snapshots in the
same base in in in the same space
uh so we proceed to do a DMD
reconstruction by the projected meshes
here is basically the relative error
um
for the reconstructions
and we've seen relative error here
and this is the is the training and then
after the training you see the trainer
is the the error increases a bit but we
have him in uh in all this DMD are good
and uh for the course
mesh is not that good but you can see in
this two slides here that the bubble
shape at that for the sign during the
sign reconstruction which is at the end
here of the training and for the
prediction within the last step is more
or less okay and we can see some really
oscillation for the course mesh and of
course in this table here you see for
several ranks DMD reconstructions and
then they see the relative error of
course uh if you increase the rank uh
you know of the reconstructions the year
or diminishes
but and uh you have you see a you know
uh astonishing a very very very nice
speed UPS so it seems to be a good idea
to uh to have all the snapshots in the
same space by projecting the solutions
so uh let's see how it GMD performs for
the quantities of Interest again I see
volume sphericity the rise velocity and
center of mass
and
I believe this is uh for using the
record I'm sorry for using the
reconstruction with 60
vectors and you see again uh
reconstruct DMD reconstruction where the
coarse mesh is good for nothing but for
the in there for defining an
intermediate projection there are of
value I mean uh you can do it without
any problem okay
so
let's now uh C is the if how this idea
of mesh projection of in having all the
snapshots in the same space
walks when we merge this with uh with
data compression so uh by using only the
final projected mesh uh here is the time
share is now on the offline file phase
is uh 90 for the servers less than one
percent of the time for output writing
uh one percent for Power view catalysts
three point three percent for the bubble
position projection the reference mesh
and the 80 for the reminder workflow
components but including uh all the
stuff you need for adaptive mat
refinement and coursing process in
litmesh uh for this specific problem you
can see here you see a a view of uh the
um for the time 2.25
um the adapt the mesh with the velociros
with the velocity plots and the
corresponding
um
projection of the level set or the
bubble position at the final mesh uh
note here that we compress both the
levels that filled on the adapter mesh
and the levels are filled on the
projected mesh
the projection mesh contain more nodes
and elements and given that there's the
same mesh for all snapshots of course it
enabled the use of DMD all the other
fields are stored in their original
adapted meshes
so here again we see the the table we
can see a the three velocity components
and then compress it and the compression
rates the pressure uh the um
the level set of this in this in adapted
mesh and the Lego set in the protected
mesh that will be used for the DMD
reconstructions you see that we achieved
some you know less we can discuss it
later why we achieve less
than in the other case but still uh good
compression rates okay and again I will
do the same thing uh this is the pick to
cyan noise ratio and we see that uh
for um zfp the lossless compression and
the same
um you know uh accuracy lever for zfp
compression
here we don't see uh you know more or
less the
lossless and zfv requested on -6 is more
or less on top of each other and the
quality of uh the aggressive more
aggressive data compression is not that
not that uh you know uh they still have
a you know a good quality uh
this is somehow
reflected when you look at the singular
values for a basis of 20 and singular
values uh we we have here all the
similar values and I'm gonna do the
reconstructions of with 20 vectors but
they're all more or less on top of each
other and uh if we look at the frobenius
norm relative Norm between the
approximate and the original snapshot
for a basis with 20 vectors we see there
are more or less the same order of
magnitude
and again uh the DMD eigenvalues if you
look at them the raw data the loss less
and the two uh uh you know compressed
and decompress it uh with different
um different tolerance there are all on
top of each other more or less
reflecting what we see in the singular
singular values
okay
so uh this is the relative on the left
relative error in time for the
reconstruction with 20 vectors we see
that that's okay it's a relative error
on time is bounded 10 to the minus two
and the time history of the bubble mess
which is
um is very very similar with the uh what
we care what we got with the no
compression at all
right
uh so so far we have been uh you know
seeing the effects of uh data compaction
and how to handle
um
uh snapshots with diff coming from when
they live in different spaces we do it
by compression and now we're gonna see
what we do when we merge uh DMD with
Institute visualization
all right some more water
um and I'm gonna do faster here uh we
see uh well do we have seen the
integration between little mesh and
parallel Catalyst and this is provided
by adapter which is implemented when on
one of the Catalyst apis more or less we
couple a live match with powerful
catalysts and we produce PNG files that
will feed streaming the DMD the adapter
invokes python scripted which is
supported for the power viewer user
interface and the adapter involves uh
this processes initialize go processing
finalize which are methods to invoke
pipelines defined in this Python scripts
uh the data structure for from the
simulation code is assessed in memory I
mean in situ and they are mapping in the
adapter using the API for Power view
catalysts and catalysts using viticates
data model to perform the data structure
mapping the user is simple if we output
PNG file every X time steps and write
data every KX time steps with K in much
more than one and PNG file files are
ingested into the streaming DMD
algorithm which is
on the right I'm not going to details
I'm just saying it's very similar to the
incremental SVD or fine in liberon
however it's tailored for receiving PNG
images uh we use this python package
opencv for handle image and scikit image
for computing metrics and the images are
converted to black and white before
processing and pixels are header has not
all values in the snapshot Matrix this
is a to make things simpler all right
so uh what we do need the streaming DMD
on the clock is changing uh computation
uh we use power of your Catalyst
generating mud images for us at the mid
plane of the all of the lock exchange
problem
uh PNG files have only this amount of
pixel with accounts for 153 megabytes to
restore all 4000 images we we we Restore
for every time step
and this is DMD reconstructor for a base
will be 250 uh uh you know uh DMD modes
okay uh usually there's no difference
between any of this uh the the full
order model image
the the the the Institute visualization
image produced a bit
online with the
order model data and uh the
reconstruction with the purview uh same
image with the DMD reconstructions
uh however I have to bear in mind that
assassin accuracy image needs more
different metrics uh why we use this
structural similarity index which is
computed like this it is very standard I
just would like to point out that uh if
this is the original image and this is
too compressed and decompressed in the
image of the PNG maybe you have a uh you
know the same MSE but this metric tells
you that this the image on the right is
much better than the middle image so
when we handle everything as images
there better use this metrics in order
to assess quality uh together with our
standard more mathematical uh
error analysis
so uh
for the lock stand problem what we
what we get when using the streaming DMD
this Mark here is uh is the mark that we
have at 350 uh snapshots in all the hair
construction keeps going with this this
snapshots or PNG files coming in and you
see this Matrix uh as close to one is
means that James images are very good
and you see by the scales that this is
true and even the DMD reconstruction
images are very good
and this is also reflected in forbino's
Norm uh in time and also in the relative
error uh they all tell us that the
Reconstruction the with this using the
images
produced in by The Institute of
visualization uh they are you know they
are DMD reconstructions are very good
what we got when we do the same thing on
the 3D Rising bubble problem
uh well now we'll generate black and
white images at the bubble midplane PNG
files have only this so uh we have a
three megabytes for storing all 240
image individual reconstruction
with rs60 and see you see the
um the
Catalyst image the ddmd Reconstruction
and so on we see here in the end
uh after the training does when the
prediction phase that DMD does not do a
good job in the Reconstruction but is
more or less we knew that when we when
we observed the Reconstruction in the
bubble perhaps is because of the
boundary conditions we we apply here
isn't is a no slit boundary condition
and this is reflected in the
in in in this other metrics uh this is
the similarity similarity index for the
Reconstruction images from the bubble
shapes is still good and we see a
degradation here in the end
again this is a you know I mean the
when you start to have a 16 started
reconstruction different
is not that good and but still tolerable
and the error is growing as we saw
before but it's still acceptable
okay
and uh we have five minutes uh should I
continue to stop here and go to the Q a
I can go very quickly on this
uh basically uh there's a uh what do you
think Tony
yeah
I think it's up to you we are pretty
flexible in the schedule okay I mean I
will jump to this because it's a more
theoretical book uh suppose we have a uh
you know a PD system that uh
uh we have this Vector here and this is
a kind of uh uh
multi-compartmental system and N is an
interoperator that defines the
interaction between an inj compartment
of course this is the places I prepared
with this season in an initial condition
for each compartment and uh depending on
the type of the equation we can use you
know to Lark in petrol Arc In A
variation mode scale for spacious
criticization
the question here is uh what we do
within within the Reconstruction it's
it's the real Freedom or each
compartment separately or
[Music]
um
but stack all of them like this and do
the DMD for the couple approach of
course this will demand more memory
um but of course in the Reconstruction
followed this expression but see uh
which one is is better uh right
in this paper below we have a
mathematical analysis and we have three
we have proved three theorems uh first
one is for a compartmental dynamic
system such that we have this
conservation the exact DMD
reconstruction uh utility here also uh
you know is conservative the second
theorem says that for a problem with
some subset of a compartment satisfies
the hypothesis of theorem one
theorem one also holds
uh for the DMD reconstruction in this
subset
the third theorem says that for a
compartmental problem which satisfy the
hypothesis of theorem one
if we have additionally that this is uh
you know uh uh this
condition here that the compartments are
are positive or zero and the MD
reconstructions are also this uh
positive or or zero at all
positions in time then we have the L1
error is bounded for all type
some remarks on this theorems this
non-negativity hypothesis on utility for
theorem trees uh it's hard to say that
it does hold in general and this
quantities may become negative but what
we see in practice that this assumption
remains satisfied for many problems at
least
for a moderate period of time after the
end of the training period
in such a regime between we may expect
that the error bound given by Tyrone 3
to hold preventing the blow up of the
era
moreover if one wishes to perform DMD on
augmented variable space let's say we
have one U2 these two compartment and a
non-linear combination of those
we would expect that this conservation
will hold in the deep diver construction
despite the presence of the non-linear
variable
the mathematical details is on the paper
I will skip this but let's see how it
works uh
this is a system of reactor diffuser
equations which basically is a special
temporal delaying uh sustainable in
Factor
um it's uh recovered and this is a
population for uh you know
simulating spreading of disease
as I said before as a stand for the
susceptible compartment e for infected
are for the covered and then D for the
season some the sum of our compartment
the deception of the deceased population
is represented by the ending population
the total number of living people the
better at the transmission rate gamers
are the simple symptomatic recovery
rates deltas and mortality rates and
here is that our diffusion tensors of
the different population groups and the
signal incorporation the lag effect
presenting between the time infection
and development symptoms and the model
sixth you know and in sixth model the
delay of service in practice when new
restriction of order measures are
introduced and then the tables of the
model is the paper in the yellow box in
in below in in the slide all right the
model works
this is the in in pink you see the
symbol in this the number of the Season
population against what was measured in
the state of Georgia in the U.S and we
observe an excellent agreement for the
total population for Georgia for this
model and uh this is uh the evolution of
the impacted infected compartment eye
for the Georgia simulation of different
phases of the pandemic they won the one
month uh four month and day
150. of course the outer break is more
was more severe around the Atlanta area
but we have other hot spots as well
uh well how DVD performs on this uh well
we're gonna see that the variation of
the you know the the mass has been
conserved and we see that if we do DMD
reconstruction we then couple uncoupled
way we see a
we don't see any conservation but
however if we do the the request DMD
reconstruction will be the couple way we
see a very good conservation even beyond
the training period
and this is the infected compartment
um you know five days after the end of
the training periods and we have a very
good agreement between uh the forward
model and the DMD reconstruction for the
couple using the couple way of doing
this
okay uh if this is your analysis and for
the Georgia simulation this is how we
compute the error and for the different
compartments the susceptible infected
recovery and this is we see that uh a
couple named the Reconstruction failed
for several compartment giving an
acceptable results in contrast uh the
couple DMD formulation you know
reconstructed the Dynamics even after
training and uh it provides reasonable
circulation for three week interval
which is a very good for the problems of
uh you know epidemic provision and um it
more or less confirms uh what the
mathematic mathematical analysis have uh
you know uh predicted for us
so final remarks and discussion to end
and then and finally go to the Q a uh
some more water before I start
my final remarks
okay uh we have seen that elastic
compression diminish the snapshot
persistent storage requirements and
contributes to decrease IO
DMD approximations use a decompressed
data may lose accuracy depending on the
singular value threshold
If lost data compression changes the
singular values before the application
Level and GMD eigenvalues may change too
and they're gonna expect and not a good
reconstruction
we have observed that decompress and
snapshot does not increase computational
effort during the MD approximation one
thing I it's I'm pretty sure data
compression is here to stay you guys in
the labs are planning a lot of effort on
doing this in in compressing compressing
uh scientific data sets so um is there
in please use it there are other options
in zfp that remains to be explored I'm
not claiming that we did the best job we
just said oh okay uh look data
compression here is good but we have to
you know to do more computations and
explore more now of course there are
other scientific data compressors work
taking a look like sdmguard plus Etc
and one thing that is important for you
guys in in the liberal Community is I
believe that any method based on
Snapshot can benefit from data
compression it's more or less obvious
this thing but uh we I never see uh many
people using you know scientific
um floating Point compression in in in
in in this method and uh we could expect
more savings for outer looping
computations
um you see uh when you do of course if
you do paramedic paramedic studies that
were generated much more data well when
you do more compression you do more and
more savings so uh you know I mean by by
using floating pointing compressions for
paramedic studies can expect much more
savings
uh
again I mean using image data for DMD
approximation presents accurate results
considering to presenting metrics with
notable storage reduction with promoting
a simple data transfer
uh another thing is projections that fix
and matches could not the best could not
be the best way of dealing with the
snapshots when in different spaces but
it's simple
why while L2 projections is embeddy in
many existing codes
uh open source codes like Live Match
Phoenix and I believe in many of the
simulation code is available the doe we
have this projections already
implemented
our experience shows that the hint is if
possible select the fixed mesh container
approximately the smallest scales
obtained in your adaptive mesh
refinement and coursing solution
uh well I mean uh
in City visualization turns the offline
in online phases blurry they are not
somehow have mixed together if it's
possible to generate in situ
visualization image targeted to the
promise queue you Qantas of Interest
short time incremental DMD prediction
can Aid steering task as runtime you see
if you are if you are receiving a bunch
of images and then doing a DMD or some
run reconstruction you can somehow
predict it at run time got gonna happen
with your assimilation and then take
action
using uh you know it uses streaming
capabilities built in in your simulation
codes
uh again I think that image metrics
should complement our traditional error
analysis look we are you you're using
images right now so you have to take a
look on the image metrics in the end
for compartmental pdes we have seen that
our Theory and have been you know uh in
America experiments have shown that a
couple DMD should be preferred
yeah that's the theme myself
um uh understand the reality our
colleague and Martha matosa from he did
from computer science he helped she
helped others a lot on the steering part
like Patrick valderez Alex vigori which
is now at CDC Malo gravy my former
student Chargers also my former student
Adriana Court as my former student
Gabriel bahus who did a lot of Works in
DMV he's finished his PhD right now but
uh a machine Learning Company in Brazil
already hired a guy and Victor Sylvan
Rena Souza also helped us a lot Victor
silver now is at Apple and the
Renaissance is your colleague in Oak
Ridge you can talk to him about this
steering stuff that he knows a lot about
this this is our you know I would like
to acknowledge our supporters and that's
it thank you so much I uh to be here
with me today and thanks for your
attention I'm ready for Q a
yeah thanks for the wonderful
photographer uh yeah I'm particularly
impressed by the comprehensive workflow
on like different uh
simulations different applications and
like the interesting error analysis
analysis on the data compression
so uh let me see I've I don't think we
have a question in the chat room yet so
uh probably I can kick off
um with one question
so uh I'm curious about like what to do
um what I mean what do you think about
like incremental DMD in the parametric
case like we have I know you you do the
sedimental transport as an example I
think you have one particular
pressure of number and uh mid number
right so yeah so if we have like
multiple of them maybe we can do it in
like simultaneously and we build the
incremental activities simultaneously so
do things like you will
um help giving a new testing parameter
another and it's in uh problem in the in
terms of the pressure and the similar
problem so how would you like do the DMD
protection there uh
that's a very good question
you see I think there is a strong
potential if you figure out the problem
with the set of visualizations figure
out you know this the script in order to
produce the images right
um if you have a parameters let's
suppose that you do a paramedic
exploration and we have a lot of jobs
running in the supercomputer and for
each one of them you are downloading uh
you know for the same point of view more
or less with the same mesh your download
the images I can think
I can
think that you can do
you can show that there's a database of
images and doing incremental DMD we can
show a new parameter and see if the
Reconstruction is okay I think this is
that that's worth doing you know worth
doing because
you're gonna check out in runtime what
it what is going to happen in this new
barometer and figure out if we have to
start a new simulation I mean yes not
good it is an indication for you okay
let's put more let's let's feel that
let's uh start simulation within the
with new parameters right
a clear application of this idea
I see yeah our group was more more
worried at that time in order to uh
complement what we have been doing in
steering in order to you know and doing
this during the indeed to predict what's
going to happen and then intervene
intervene in the code but what you have
said is really I do agree with you if
you have if you figure out for let's say
the same configuration and several
parameters and you have the images you
can you just expose your streaming DMD
to this new parameter and see if it's
worthwhile to increase your parameter
space or not yeah
yeah that's right I think you can pop
more on this matter because the liberal
team we uh we are also looking at like
uh having automatic like error
indicators for like finding
um the parameters that we have to like
build more snapshots for like having a
better Universal uh estimation in the
whole parametric domain so yeah maybe we
will learn from your experience and
maybe you can also talk about our work
in the residual driven uh
um like sampling methods there yeah Tony
that's that's absolutely right I mean
you could use for instance a k n or any
other better to combine all these things
uh or an area neural network to you know
I mean uh to do this but it's absolutely
correct I think you you the team is uh
you need to do that it's about doing
yep so uh I may ask one more question
um so uh so it is like uh I don't have a
clear idea about this but
um you I mean in the hotel we mainly
work I mean talking about these
simulations but so I'm thinking about
like a data I mean a decision making uh
process or a like multi-curry problems
so usually we want to match the
simulation with some kind of of shelf
data and there are some noise in there
so do you have like any comments on some
insights on how the noise level is
um I mean related or affecting the like
the zfp compression level that you
should choose in the DMD
um
that's a very good question
uh
you've seen uh just to
yeah those things here uh
big sign of the noise of racism is uh it
is a measure
the guys who wrote this
um this paper I I quoted here uh where
uh
yeah those guys
though those guys here for the Benchmark
they test it
and they they uh there is a uh uh
um
a um let's say
they propose a benchmark which all this
compressor and
um this is those guys they are one of
the quantities that is new to our
community at least we don't tell much
about this is this big cyan noise ratio
and tells you how this noise generated
by the compression affects your your
your snapshots in the end when you
decompress how it is how how how your
snapshots will be affected
so I mean compressing and decompressing
by something like uh you know 75 to 80
or is considered good
this come from from from those uh image
guys
you see when we're doing this uh we went
to the the image literature uh if you
take a look on the on on the on the
paper where we did that we we quote a
image book this is something new for us
CSC guys but it's bread and butter for
for the image guys so I'm saying that
that's why I said in the end that uh
there's more on data compression and and
that's why we choose uh zfp in the
beginning because there is a strong
mathematical background and error
analysis for zfp as well as for the
other uh uh compressor
is one
M guard Plus
there's a strong mathematical background
in this mgar plus so it's War I mean I
it's hard to say at that point which one
is is the best one but again I I
um
I I repeat what I wrote here data
compression history is here to stay
so it's something that our community has
to start coping with and our experiment
says just say to us that oh okay it's a
it's not that bad we can cope with this
because we're gonna restart receiving
data there that are only available in in
the compressed form yes these are too
big
yeah I totally agree like espresso is
interesting uh like the zfp they are
actively researched in within the cost
of area now and we'll probably we will
certainly want to like incorporate these
techniques in the liberal that we are
developing to like yeah I mean they are
for instance a cfp is part of the hdf5
there's a plug-in for this yes and I'm
I'm pretty sure that you guys in the
labs don't just go for the access scale
project guys and talk to them you'll be
readily available yes okay yeah so uh
let me ask once more are there any more
questions from the audience
um so if there are no more questions
let's thank everyone again for sharing
his excellent research with us
okay